obtengamos un poco de práctica restando
fracciones mixtas digamos por ejemplo
que tenemos dos y cinco octavos y le
queremos restar un entero y dos octavos
y bueno pues te recomiendo que le pongas
una pausa a este vídeo e intentes hacer
esta resta por tu cuenta
bueno una forma de hacer esta resta es
colocar por aquí estos dos números
mixtos podemos poner por aquí dos y
cinco octavos y por aquí uno y dos
octavos y estamos restando y luego pues
podemos fijarnos en esta columna aquí
tenemos puros octavos tenemos cinco
octavos y queremos restarle dos octavos
y cuando tenemos cinco de una cosa y le
restamos dos de una cosa pues nos quedan
tres de esa cosa y en este caso esa cosa
son octavos
entonces nos quedan tres octavos y luego
en esta otra columna tenemos puros
enteros aunque tenemos dos enteros y le
queremos restar un entero entonces pues
nos queda un entero así es que esto de
aquí es igual a un entero y tres octavos
ahora vamos a hacer un ejercicio más
interesante aunque digamos por ejemplo
que tenemos tres enteros y dos quintos y
le vamos a restar dos enteros y tres
quintos y como siempre ponle pausa al
vídeo e intenta hacer esta resta por tu
cuenta
listo bueno vamos a intentar resolver
esta resta de la misma forma como lo
hicimos por aquí entonces vamos a
escribir por aquí tres enteros y dos
quintos menos dos enteros y tres quintos
dos enteros y tres quintos aunque
empezamos por esta columna por aquí en
esta resta fue súper sencillo porque
teníamos cinco octavos menos dos octavos
y eso claramente son tres octavos sin
embargo aquí tenemos dos quintos menos
tres quintos pero dos quintos es un
número más chico que tres quintos
entonces cómo le vamos a hacer bueno
pues una de las opciones que tenemos es
reagrupar no crear y aquí tenemos tres
enteros y podemos tomar un entero y
convertirlo en fracción y entonces ya
vamos a tener un número suficientemente
grande como para que sea fácil restarle
tres quintos no cree entonces de estos
tres enteros vamos a tomar prestado uno
y entonces nos quedan dos enteros y ese
otro entero lo vamos a convertir a
fracción un entero es igual a cinco
quintos no acá hay dos más cinco quintos
es igual a tres y bueno dos quintos más
cinco quintos es igual a siete quintos
entonces nos quedan dos y siete quintos
ok de hecho hasta lo podríamos escribir
por aquí
gheit tres y dos quintos
es exactamente igual a dos y siete
quintos hay dos y siete quintos
estos dos números son equivalentes y por
qué pues porque tomé uno de estos
enteros y entonces me quedaron dos
enteros y ese entero lo convertía
fracción y se lo sume a esta fracción y
entonces nos quedaron siete quintos ok
porque un entero es igual a cinco
quintos y ya que reescribimos a este
número como dos y siete quintos dos y
siete quintos entonces ya estamos listos
para hacer esta resta tomamos siete
quintos y le restamos tres quintos y nos
quedan cuatro quintos y luego tenemos
dos menos dos pero pues 2 menos 12 0 así
es que el total de esta resta es cuatro
quintos entonces esta resta es igual a
cuatro quintos bueno ahora vamos a hacer
otro de estos ejercicios en los que
tenemos que reagrupar
enteros y fracciones digamos por ejemplo
que tenemos siete y un sexto y le vamos
a restar cuatro y no sé digamos que
cinco sextos cinco sextos y estamos
restando tenemos un sexto y le queremos
restar cinco sextos pero pues no está
muy fácil hacer eso porque un sexto es
más chico que cinco sextos entonces lo
que vamos a hacer al igual que en el
ejercicio pasado es pedirle un entero
prestado a este 7 entonces le pedimos
uno prestado y nos quedan 6
y s entero que nos está prestando el 7
lo vamos a convertir a fracción lo vamos
a convertir a 6 sextos y entonces
sumamos esos 6 sextos más un sexto y nos
queda 7 sextos
no creo que vamos a volver a explicar
esta parte paso por paso teníamos aquí
un sexto pero necesitamos una fracción
más grande entonces vamos y le pedimos
un entero prestado a este 7 que le
pedimos un entero prestado y entonces
nos quedan 6 enteros y luego este entero
que nos está prestando lo vamos a
convertir a fracción y nos conviene una
fracción que tenga sextos como
denominador entonces vamos a escribir 1
como 6
sextos no case 6 sextos es igual a un
entero y entonces tenemos seis enteros
más un entero que nos está prestando en
la forma de seis sextos pero le tenemos
que sumar este un sexto que ya teníamos
entonces nos queda un sexto más seis
sextos que es igual a siete sextos y la
razón por la que estamos haciendo todo
este relajo es para que nos quede una
fracción más grande y podamos hacer esta
resta entonces tenemos siete sextos
menos cinco sextos y eso pues son dos
sextos y en la columna de los enteros
tenemos seis menos cuatro que son dos
entonces el resultado de esta resta es
dos y dos sextos pero bueno esta
fracción de aquí todavía se puede
simplificar un poquito más porque el 2
divide al número
y el denominador entonces pues
simplificando este número mixto
obtenemos dos enteros y dos sextos es
equivalente a un tercio y listo también
lo podemos escribir de esta forma